que faire quand une bête sauvage décide
de s'installer dans notre cours ou même
dans notre grenier certains animaux
comme les écureuils les moufettes et les
ratons laveurs sont de plus en plus
nombreux en ville et ce qui complique
les choses c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
règles claires pour encadrer la gestion
de la petite faune en milieu urbain
[Musique]
on a vraiment créé un refuge à
l'intérieur de nos villes pour ces
animaux là
le dessous de ton cabanon c'est un condo
animaux les mangeoires d'oiseaux c'est
un buffet animaux sauvage tes arbres
fruitiers s'attirent la forme
j'ai des voisins et les autres il y aime
ça les oiseaux
vous pouvez avec ça
[Musique]
on reçoit les animaux sauvages blessés
ou orphelin on leur donne une seconde
chance parce que ils sont de plus en
plus en détresse de par l'étalement
urbain
cette technicienne en aménagement de la
faune dirige depuis près de 10 ans un
refuge pour animaux sauvages la petite
faune surtout nous on a quatre
biologiste qui travaille au refuge donc
on travaille tous ensemble sur les 6000
animaux qui sont arrivés ici depuis 2014
90% du temps c'était pour des raisons
humaines donc frappé par des voitures ça
peut être pris dans un piège ça peut
être parce que la mère a été relocalisée
puis les bébés ont été retrouvés
orphelins ça c'est notre lot quotidien
il y a des gens aussi qui achètent
toutes sortes de pierres ou prend le
piège du voisin ou un vieux piège en
sous-sol puis là il installe des choses
parce qu'il y a un intolérance on a reçu
une fête avec le néperie dedans ici
c'est la moufette qu'on vous a montré
aujourd'hui elle avait deux pattes
dedans on attend laveur le corps c'est
beaucoup de souffrance animale pour
beaucoup d'intolérance c'est d'une
grande tristesse
pour la plupart de ces petits animaux
sauvages ils ont eu la malchance de se
retrouver un peu trop près d'un humain
situations les gens vont avoir peur ou
vont pas tolérer la présence d'un animal
sauvage c'est pas de la méchanceté c'est
vraiment un manque de connaissance la
Fédération des trappeurs gestionnaires
le dit elle-même que si tu regardes pas
le problème à la base tu vois juste le
problème va revenir
[Musique]
j'entendais marcher sur le toit ça se
promenait puis elle m'a donné je suis
allée dans la rue j'ai vu la mer sur le
bord du toit là-bas il y avait une
moquette qui sauvent cette citoyenne de
Lévy n'a jamais vu autant de petits
animaux sauvages dans son quartier cette
fois-ci une famille de laveurs
s'est installé dans son entretoise
qui peuvent rentrer parce que il y a
deux ventilations en forme de J alors
avant d'intervenir Michel Gamache donne
ses recommandations à sa cliente
anti laveur pour pas qu'il
revienne c'est professionnel du piégeage
sont en forte demande dans nos villes et
banlieues il n'y a pas si longtemps ils
étaient surtout à l'oeuvre durant la
période réglementaire de trapage
d'animaux à fourrure tard l'automne et
durant l'hiver
puis les petits s'ils veulent déranger
de la mer depuis quelques années ils
doivent en plus répondre aux plaintes de
citadins qui cohabitent avec cette
petite faune
mon voisin avait deux ratons l'avare
mort dans cette piscine et la même
journée j'étais assise sur mon patio
puis arrêtant la barre est arrivé sur le
patio et Madame
[Musique]
[Rires]
nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on met un
appât dans la cage cette spécialiste en
écologie animale et catégorique nous
avons créé un nouvel écosystème pour la
petite faune
un environnement qui favorise leur
survie mais aussi leur reproduction en
milieu urbain il y a des évidences à
l'altération qui montrent qu'ils ont
plus de jeunes qui m'assurent plus
rapidement donc qui sont très bons à
occuper ce milieu et donc que les
densités seraient en augmentation le
dans certains endroits effectivement
donc plus on a des milieux qui sont
urbains verts plus on crée ces
habitats-là qui sont intéressants même
chose pour la façon dont on gère nos
déchettent on fournit de la nourriture
avec là après on a choisi pas qui vient
la manger
là pour la nuit en espérant que les
petits décembre
qu'on retrouve ici tout un environnement
idéal pour une moufette pour un ratat
laveur pour démarre boîte qu'on a de
l'eau on a de la on a probablement des
voisins qui nourrissent des oiseaux on a
probablement des jardins on a probable
on a des fleurs en masse du compost
aussi fait qu'ils vont tirer profit ils
vont vraiment s'alimenter à partir de ça
passera en arrière puis trembler
être à peur depuis 35 ans il reçoit de
plus en plus d'appels de citoyens
dérangés par la présence d'un petit
animal sauvage
ok je vais y aller il contactent ensuite
un membre de son association régionale
pour le secteur concerné
on a trois
ne croyait pas devoir faire appel à un
trappeur comme plusieurs citoyens elle a
d'abord pensé à l'exterminateur moi je
vous dis j'ai appelé une compagnie
d'extermination mais en ayant dans la
taille tu viendras pas exterminer les
animaux jean-Marc Couture est
spécialement formé pour piéger ou
tremper la petite faune avec les bonnes
cages et les bons appâts les gens
pensent tout le temps qu'on met de la
sardine la sardine
on peut prendre nos moufettes
un moment donné c'est de sécuriser les
cabanons pour pas
dans la grande majorité des cas les
petits animaux sauvages capturés en
milieu urbain par les trappeurs
certifiés sont relocalisés dans un autre
milieu plus loin des secteurs habités
quand on les relocalise il y a des
études qui ont montré que plusieurs fois
qu'on fait de la transplantation
d'animaux comme ça la majorité vont
mourir dans les premiers semaines
premier jour qu'on les relocalise puis
c'est sûr que c'est difficile pour le
citoyen de s'y retrouver qui qu'est-ce
que je fais des fois ils vont gérer le
problème aux autres même ils vont donner
un coup de pelle à l'animal tu sais je
ne peux pas dire tout ce qui se passe au
Québec tous les biologistes et autres
experts à qui nous avons parlé
s'entendre pour dire que la solution
pense d'abord par le citoyen et les
bonnes habitudes à prendre pour mieux
cohabiter avec ces nouveaux voisins
comme par exemple sécuriser les ordures
ménagères éviter les mangeoires
d'oiseaux protégés jardin et potager et
fermez tous les accès ou les petits
mammifères peuvent s'établir et se
reproduire nous par exemple cet été j'ai
une demande de 250 localisations
puis on en a fait trois donc nous on
essaie de pas juste déplacer le problème
on accompagne les gens sur comment
changer quelques habitudes parce que
c'est sûr que des poules en ville pour
des ratons laveurs c'est comme comment
je dois faire pour les manger là
tout comme la chasse et la pêche les
activités de piégeage au Québec sont
réglementées
selon la loi une personne ne peut tuer
ou capturer un animal qui l'attaque ou
qui cause du dommage à ses biens
lorsqu'elle peut les faire oucher ou
l'empêcher de causer des dégâts en
d'autres mots on peut le capturer le
déplacer ou l'abattre mais en tout
dernier recours et le dernier recours
relève bien souvent de l'interprétation
parce que là n'importe qui intervient
n'importe comment n'importe où sans
nécessairement de qualification puissant
nécessairement de préoccupation au
niveau du bien-être animal si on veut
que ces animaux-là soient traités de
façon poétique ça serait de demander aux
gens d'avoir des permis comme pour
d'autres types de chasse ou autre
[Musique]
par exemple des cages comme celle-ci
sont en vente libre dans plusieurs
grandes quincaillerie
de mes projets de recherche j'ai
énormément d'exigences et de permis à
obtenir autant du provincial que de
Santé Canada si c'était un laveur
par exemple qui est dans la cage des
animaux qui sont très agressifs c'est
des animaux qui peuvent être porteurs de
la rage qui est une maladie vraiment
très grave chez le même c'est aussi
porteur de toutes sortes d'autres
parasites avec lesquels on veut pas
vraiment être en contact les piégeurs
professionnels réclament d’ailleurs du
ministère de la faune un cadre
réglementaire plus strict pour
intervenir en milieu urbain comme des
pièges homologués et une formation
adaptée à ce nouveau type de piégeage
réalisé directement chez le citoyen et
en dehors de la saison de trapège
traditionnel en forêt c'est le ministère
qui devrait tout simplement favoriser
une formation pour intervenir en milieu
urbain
pour l'instant le ministère responsable
de la faune réfère les citoyens
concernés aux associations de piégeurs
professionnels et rappelle les mesures
de base pour mieux cohabiter avec les
petits animaux sauvages on a pris toutes
leurs espaces donc sont là puis l'humain
est au centre de de tout au niveau de la
faune en tout cas on
a beaucoup pas faire
[Musique]